okay here we are for another design
review our fourth one in the day today
as as we get ready for version
14 um and we are looking at a variety of
uh General special
projects
um yes okay units first yeah so
Nick yeah so spectacularly faster yes we
are unit conversion is basically down to
evaluator time um so we're around a
microc or two for most unit con you call
speed of
light yeah basically basically as fast
as you mean in that thing I just wrote
no I don't know we we call it speed of
light for the evaluator like we can't we
can't touch the
system yeah okay this is cool what's a
good example where I can where I can try
a big unit conversion of a whole array
of things let's say
um uh well I don't
know I mean it's just like that's great
I I don't know what else to
say um Y what about things like currency
conversions temperature conversions
things like this yep so currency
conversions are as fast as they can be
so the the behind the scenes part is
basically we've reimplemented unit
convert entirely within the kernel where
we don't need to make top level calls
for anything there's a data storage
system that we it wasn't done with the
compiler how
come was was it done with the compiler
it wasn't done specifically with the
compiler no I mean it's a shame there
yeah there there are reasons for it um
because of the data structures we're
working with it was more expedient and
and more efficient to do it within the C
code itself but basically we can do all
the conversions we need to do with the
exception of currency conversion without
needing to make any top level calls
currency conversion we still have to
call out to right and presumably caching
once you did the dollar pound conversion
in that in that evaluation you cash it
yes it's done for that evaluation but we
do still do real time lookup so if you
re if there's a new call to the
evaluator if you what is our window for
Real Time lookup I mean in other words
if if it's I don't know how fast the
real time lookup is in other words how
can it change in a
second I don't think it changes in a
second I don't I mean we we're on a mild
delay and it varies time of day you know
the currency exchanges don't update
constantly
um why is this Offset you know I've
reported this 700 times when it's
magnified it's
offset do you see what I'm saying yeah
some baseline issue there or Bas yeah so
I mean can we please get this fixed
please Eli I think you're project
managing so could you please take this
to the front end team and try and get it
f
fixed sure
thank I thought currency
convert why does it have that
thing
um okay I don't know
F boy that's not so bad that was it was
really cruder than that a while back
yeah it was there there we've done a
couple of rounds but this is kind of the
no I was looking I was talking about the
dollar bound conversion pound conversion
I see yeah um but yeah go ahead what
were you gonna say yeah I was GNA say
there there have been a couple of passes
in improving things but basically what
we've done is that there
are uh you know each unit basically has
rules about what its fundamental unit
value is which for basically everything
that is at a temperature is zero and
what its fundamental conversion to its
SI base unit is and so we have that data
available in the kernel whenever we do
conversions we look that up and then
cach it in the kernel and if we're doing
something like an evaluation where we
have a bunch of uh you know if you had
an array
of values in pounds and then you
converted it to Dollars we would look up
the currency exchange once and then be
able to do that conver all the way
through I understand so you're doing the
same yeah okay I understand that I I
think you should talk to the data people
to find out how how quickly this
actually changes if we can put a time to
live of even if it's you know five
minutes or something then exactly okay
it would
help all right great stuff that's really
cool I'm really excited about
that all right let's go to astronomy
okay so so the the big thing for us this
time is eclipses so preparing for
doesn't wait or Moon doesn't wait so
whatever I released is our we got to get
it in this
release yes no I'm sorry I'm just making
a silly
comment um um isn't there isn't there an
infinite set of
them isn't it like primes there's just
an infinite set of solar
eclipses uh yes well actually there wer
no there is not an infinite set the Moon
is getting further away from the earth
uh well wa I mean also we probably only
have four billion years so
left right right so so what we can
handle here is 30,000 years of eclipses
wow which it uh it amounts about
72,000 of
them and
so yes so the next one is going to be in
a few weeks it's going to be an anular
eclipse and actually French champagne
with glasses we will be able to see the
sun half covered more or less oh cool
yep but the the big one is next year in
in
April and uh yeah let see let me see
where it's visible
from how do I compute where it's visible
from uh sorry what did you say how do I
compute where the where the April how do
I get to the next eclipse first of all
yeah so look for solar eclipse um
Eclipse type goes to total so that will
look for the next one that is
total so this is a function that existed
so we are keeping the
the why is it taking so long can't you
just generally set the dates uh Jose why
is this taking so long for goodness sake
cash the next few years of
eclipses it it shouldn't be taking so
long this is super fast for me as
something is not right as I'm
fortunate but generally you set the date
right and then it looks forward yeah so
the the syntax is you specify a date and
then it looks for the next one of of the
given type oh
no that's
unfortunate what's dollar
version yes do
um okay
um can you send me an notebook the the
the results from
this do you have examples for any of
these what we should do is to look at
the page I mean either either I show the
evaluations in my machine or we look at
the at the ref page which has all the
evaluations of this
sort the page is called solar eclipse
new because we are uh completely
rewriting the page is it new with all
caps or just one cap just
one
unfortunate so if you go to basic
examples further than there should be
something like
this that's an ugly picture if I might
say so yes so this this requires uh re
redesign it's it's a it's a map showing
all the elements we can discuss now all
the elements of of the map right that's
the totality PA wow this one is really
going across a lot of the US does it go
through
champagne uh very close we will still
need goes through Southeast Indianapolis
and it goes through Carbondale again so
if you're in carbon Dale last time for
the 2017 and it's going to go through
there uh that was x marks the spot oh I
remember that blog post you wrote about
that where is there up here how how
close does it go to the um to
Massachusetts for example how do I find
out what the closest place to conquer
Massachusetts in the eclipse path
is well we have a polygon for the
totality path it would be a matter
finding the the closest place in in that
polygon we also have now the ability to
compute for example What's the magnitude
that I will see from this
place so yes one of the things that has
now this function is that it has the
ability to compute everything from for a
given date and for a given location or
both so it allows realtime monitoring of
the clips from
anywhere and these are all important
lines for example the green lines are
lines of magnitude of the observation
magnitude means the fraction of the
diameter of the sun covered by the moon
so this this increases in in a steps of
0.2 okay this is the initial eclipse
this is maximum point to maximum eclipse
and so on exactly so the green line is
where the Umbra is so the white line is
where the Umbra is and then the green
lines are levels of
penumbra what are the red lines the red
lines are is called the racing and
setting uh curves of the and this is the
in in all those places you will see the
the eclipse happening at Sunrise and in
the yellow lines which you go through
the middle is the places where you see
the maximum of the eclipse precisely at
Sun
lines I
see and then those lines have a very
interesting geometry for partial
eclipses they can join above so they are
not always separate lines there are
examples for along
multiple geometric configurations we
need graphic design for this this looks
terrible right now I mean the
functionality is fantastic but the
design is terrible that's that's bar
that's brand new as of today that
property didn't even exist yet so I see
okay okay so there are for example now
we can this is the called SOS inex
Panorama so every Eclipse can be
identified by two numbers the SOS cycle
which is the horizontal the x coordinate
and the up the vertical number that's
the index number and so as opposed to
index it's the inex it's the inex yes
the s number was known by the Greeks I
know yeah right long ago it's in the
anti device the index number was
discovered in 1950 more or
less so that's very interesting so every
eclipse is in one of those uh lines so
the the lower picture is what we can
compute all these
blue uh are the eclipses we can compute
the black white ones are those that NASA
had computed until now oh that's cool
yeah so we can confirm that and uh I
compute many
more which one did thy
see sorry phy saw an eclipse in the in
during a battle between the Persians and
the something or other right right so by
the way you your your audio um Jose is
keeps on semi- breing up
sounds like you're talking through a
reverberator or talking through a
fan I'm sorry about that I'm using the
same
configuration of every other day I'm I'm
at the
office that's really
weird sorry about that okay so the claim
is the eclipse occurred on 28th of May
BC um well I'm not sure how much does it
work in your computer so if you add just
the date to solar
eclipse does it
work without the the
option I mean I don't even know what the
date means in but let's say
uh 585
BC no this oh
yes um what's that dash dash doing that
doesn't seem right minus 1500 to minus
oh gosh
I arguable that's not
perfect okay it should have been immed
absolutely immediate after after it
finished the yeah so something is not
right there
um okay so something is not working with
the typ then okay so now if I now say
solar eclipse of this do I get the next
solar eclipse no should be the same one
we have a a tolerance of a day so that
you can keep asking for properties of
that SP if you ask for solar eclipse of
that plus a month then it will jump to
the next
one how many solar cses were there in
this freaking year well no
again that's sorry that's they are aart
they should be apart like six months or
something not not necessarily they can
be five in a
year yes yes in in general but but it it
happens very
rarely no well okay so this one
says I mean like the Wikipedia page says
28 of May but it might be complete
nonsense um we're saying there was one
on the 22nd of May
this may be the same bug I was saying
Jose where I think what it's doing is
it's jumping to the next new moon not
necessarily the next eclipse yeah so
something's going wrong and resolving
what it's doing is it's looking at the
next lunation number but that's not
necessarily the part that says okay is
that an eclipse and that's failing and
it's just stopping at the lunation
number yeah so this this is something
that I I have not been able to reproduce
in my machine or other machines we have
tried but you have had seen it we
thought it was a Windows problem that we
were looking into this week but
we to be affecting you as well
potentially the calendar switch over
problem if we're a few days off it might
be Gregorian versus Julian well I was
thinking about that yeah no but this is
different this is different it's
something that we we had seen in in in
in Jeff's machine
so
so yeah so as I said I we can check
these things in my in my machine or uh
yeah I I we should at this again in a in
a few days when you have this
unscrambled yeah so so there are two
things that we should do today one is
look at the the very many new properties
that we have and the second thing is to
look at some other functions because in
order to work with eclipses is very
important to have very good information
about the moon so we are proposing new
functions to handle the moon they are at
at the at the end of that okay let's
look at these okay astr Graphics so yes
that part is is not ready yet so ignore
this part and let's look at the six new
functions that wait do you see the stuff
Christopher made recently using astr
Graphics we have been talking about it
yet but I'm not sure I know what you
mean that's this post oh yes oh yes
that's yeah he had me add tm's catalog
of stars to Star data so we now have an
entity class of all those Stars ah very
good I thought it was kind of cool the I
think he has a picture
at the end of uh the stars in order in
tmy
catalog yeah this is very nice right but
so this is yeah I mean this is just
directly using asog Graphics presumably
with the tmy star catalog which
apparently is now in the
system it will be it will be it's on
current but it's not on production yet
okay the
um but so what's well okay this is just
I mean to what to what to what extent
and we're going to look at this another
time but to what extent do you now think
you've reached the final state for Astor
Graphics so so the the treatment of
spherical geometry is is is going to be
now a lot more solid and and this is
something that I was doing also for for
Geographics but it's not ready for
Geographics yet so it's going to be
first released in in asog graphics and
then in the next round we will do it for
Geographics okay and um yeah what aspect
of of spherical geometry is not was not
already this is so fundamentally the the
manipulation of the vector Primitives so
not making errors when we have very
large Primitives in the projections and
the
rotations um so those Primitives then
need to be like if you have a really
long line you need to split you know to
segment it more yeah right see what I'm
saying y yeah no I mean the coordinate
chart adaptive subdivision basically
exactly and what's happened to sphere
position and all those or spherical
spherical position spherical distance
all those kinds of
things so so we are working on another
of those functions to compute angles you
will see that in in the I meeting next
week okay but um we don't have yet a
full uh set of of spherical Primitives
or anything like that what about
sperical
Graphics well astrographic and in the
future Geographics are going to be
called internally something called SPH
Graphics but I think eventually we could
look at it I think we should expose that
because I mean that's that's a thing
that is
useful you
know yeah okay I think it's a separate
project
and when it's battle tested with asog
graphics and Geographics we will be more
sure that it's the the
solid okay moon phase
date yes so this is a function to handle
everything related to the facee of the
Moon we have moon
phase right which shows you the current
phase but this is telling you the date
when a certain phase will be achieved
exactly and it has two particular cases
which I think are are important enough
to deserve separate functions which
are yeah I mean are just particular
cases I understand I mean people have
been observing the new moon and full
moon throughout human history so I guess
we should give them
functions y they feel like sunrise and
sunset yeah I agree too important to to
not be
there but Moon moonface state is the one
doing any type of
of of of um moon phase and even it it
it's controlled by a number that goes
from Z to one so zero is a yeah I get it
y
right and then I'm gonna ask for you
know given that everybody's interested
in Mars we could ask for the same thing
I mean are we going to support
non-terrestrial moon computations like
this um we could but it it's not done
yet could be done okay I I don't think
it's
urgent but it would certainly be I mean
we can presumably we know becomes
ambiguous when you talk about Mars or
any planet with multiple moons which
moon you're talking about I know you
have to say you have to say the planet
and the Moon I mean if you specify the
name of the Moon there then it's it
specifies both the planet and the
moon we got only a few years and then
there'll start to be moons of exoplanets
discovered but that's a while you know
that's some distance
why
um yes there are rough Pages for those
functions if you want to look at them
and then lunation number and from
lunation number are a pair like Julian
date and from Julian date and they are
counting of lunar
months so including fractional including
fractional indeed yeah so this is a
account this is a telling of time by
lunar
uh uh by
new why on Earth is that the First new
moon of 2000 this is a convention what's
that this is a convention and Below you
see that there are several conventions
that have been
suggested so so again it's like Julian
data has several
pipes I call them here schemes they
could be called types like can jul
types call them what Julian date has a
first argument called T and it can be a
modified lunar Julian date
Etc so here there are
also different cting sches
okay I don't understand this I mean the
moon went round a certain number of
times so I don't understand what these
different counting schemes correspond to
it's the choice of of the first
one they all they all defer by a
shift by I see I see I see I see I see
it's just where the where the the zero
of lunation is so to speak
exactly for example there is an Islamic
uh com because the day of
the said happened very close to one of
so they count moons from
there why
oh Brown was one of the guys who worked
on some emeris
right uh
yes and was that his birthday or
something no he would have been that
that's that's too that's too late for
his birthday for his birth date yeah
perhaps why the heck did he pick that
date that I don't know I really don't
know
okay uh so this is also related to
calendar for example Astro
subo yes that's one of the new functions
as well so that's that's the point in on
the earth that has it so for example
Astro subo of
the that correct I mean that must be
correct sorry can you repeat that again
I didn't I said subo of the sun will be
the point on the Earth
where yes there where the sun is
directly overhead
exactly yes and and this is called a
subsolar
point
okay yes so the the maximum latitude of
this Subs solar point and the minimum
Define the tropics
yes I'm going to have to leave Stephen
you guys continue and we have another
one scheduled tomorrow to continue this
for
tomorrow okay okay see you see you Roger
bye
um so in all the maps about eclipses
it's very typical to give this the sub
points of the of the sun and the
moon but this can be computed for any
object I
see I see so in fact not just objects
but also Astro positions I'm assuming
Jose like does it work I'm sure I'm sure
it does does it work
for right now it's it's not
uh but it could I guess it could but
right now right now it wants an
object but I think it should allow an
astop position because it must just
compute it the same way so is that
obvious that's the North Pole close to
the North Pole is that correct or am I
confused exactly no no it it it has to
be close to the North Pole but it's not
exactly because the polarity is close
but not exactly I know I know I know I
know that's pretty close
actually that's cool by the way you
could use that as an example
presumably polar pole I think it right
okay fine all right you want to look at
the uh the eclipse thing and then we
wrap up for today I think uh yes I would
suggest also a nice example in from
lunation number
P because number what's yes from
lunation number it's one of the reasons
why this function is also
important if you go to the I think it's
an application
example or perhaps a property AR
relation this one with the with the
histograms so if you take the the days
of new moons in the Gregorian calendar
you take the day of the month they
happen to fall everywhere all over the
months but if you change those same
dates to the Jewish calendar
you see how they always fall at the end
of month because the US calendar is
lunis Sola so it follows
the that's very cute so the same thing
happens with the with the Chinese
calendar and all
Lun okay yeah no it's
[Music]
nice okay
so is there anything particularly I mean
by the way I mean in terms of these
Computing the
eclipses
and your plot of
um these time scales and so on I mean we
ran the emities presumably over what's
said yes we do use the EMES
yes but so then what we were using then
I suppose
and then we're looking for coges based
on the ephes is that
right uh no the technique is the
following we know that every solar
eclipse is going to be very very close
to a new we have very fast methods to
find the new moons and so what we do is
to analyze whether in a given New Moon
there is an eclipse or
not what do you mean in a given New Moon
you mean on the day of a given New Moon
yes near an instant every every every
solar eclipse if it happens it happens
within 15 minutes of an oh I see so it's
very easy to know whether a given numon
is going to be an eclipse or
not and so to do that we use the velan
elements which are there so we compute
the velan elements which are these
functions and from those functions which
are polinomial of the third degree we
compute everything else with high
Precision right and and um
yeah so that that that's the technique
so first find whether a given new moon
is an eclipse and if it is then compute
velan elements and compute every signs
from
there and so these bellan elements are a
cubic polinomial basically a coefficient
of Cub polinomial is that correct yes
that is that is a tradition because it's
good enough everything is going to
happen within two hours of the center or
three hours with right
so I'm just thinking I don't know why
we're not keeping the bellan elements as
interpolating
functions we could we could and that's
one of the things we could Doan the
tradition is to report these tables of
numbers if you want to compare with
tables from nas yeah I understand but
maybe we could call it
Bellion I what the what what is the
thing you're Computing here the those
coefficients we could comp I mean what
we do is that we call the FES and then
do a fit of the polinomial so we could
do an interpolating function which is
just these pols yeah I understand but I
mean there are a bunch of pols and each
different polinomial is representing a
different thing yes right X and Y for
example are the positions in X and Y and
basically orthographic projection um
coordinates of where the Moon Shadow
falls on a plane that cuts through the
Earth yeah um declination is what
declination of the sun is that right yes
um Dem the AIS the shadow yeah I don't
remember what mu is um it's our angle
it's the rotation of but I mean so do we
have if we made an association we had
names for these different elements and
we had the right hand side be an
interpolating function do we have names
for those elements that fit in with
things that are up
here um we could we
could I mean there are properties right
now that um evaluate the individual ver
elements but evalate what
so there could be properties that
evaluate individual basan elements or we
could have a basan element functions no
that's what I'm saying bellan element
rules or something bellan element
functions sounds like a good thing to
have what I'm asking is in the bellan
element functions are there obvious
names for those elements you call them X
and Y and things like this are there
obvious names for that based on what you
have based on the names that you have
here that you can compute for an eclipse
so we could call them Shadow axis X for
example so there are standard names that
are used in all books I mean this was
done by by Bessel in in 1824
interestingly so next year it's going to
be 200 years so um so all books use the
same name so so it's very standard okay
well so fine so we can have an
association which has those names arrow
and interpolating
function yeah or the
well I think an interpretating function
is nicer because it means that we don't
have to give a
variable yes we can directly use it
because I think most of the time on on
and we should have the bellian elements
table as
well have we already had bellan elements
as a as a property before
no well we should probably call it
Belling elements give the table and then
we should say Belling element function
functions
so something something new as well is
that now we have these properties that
depend on time and and location and so
what we do is that we use list name of
the property comma date comma location
or my they
but for example yes they are at the
end
exactly rather than having a separate
argument because that that date would
not
to most of the things here
exactly seems reasonable to
me
okay any other things we should look at
right now no no I think we have to I
will say we've had some pretty
interesting manipulates when things are
working they work they work very nice
you can have real-time manipulates and
show the shadow moving across the face
of the Earth and even see the Distortion
of the shape of the umber as it moves
across as it goes glancing across across
the surface wow and it's really fast I
mean
it's wow very nice that's cool all right
I look forward tomorrow to seeing it
let's make sure we check that I have the
right version of my machine for
tomorrow um okay not sure one day is
enough yeah but we say okay well but
maybe yeah what the problems are we have
to make sure they're fixed and we don't
know what the problems are yet so yeah
okay fine fine or we can't ector you'll
share okay um okay good work thanks a
lot see you tomorrow see you bye
bye